our next german video from 2011 shows
the marriage of nature and technology no
it's not a bird
it's not a plane this is the man made
smart bird
we flew to Germany to speak to the man
behind the video dr. Heinrich Fonzie
there's a huge difference between
flapping mechanism and this optimized
flying operations of the real bird and
we did it in this flying robot over 2.3
million people have marveled at the
magnificent flying machine so why is it
called smart bird
we called this flight model smart bird
because there's a lot of technology
inside which is very very smart Thank
You Heinrich so how did these German
engineers conquer flight the most
difficult thing about recreating a
bird's wing is how complex they are they
have very complicated shapes that twist
bend and move up and down and that is
not an easy shape to get a machine to
recreate so rather than having fixed
wings like an aeroplane or a glider it
has several joints in the wings allowing
it to bend flex and twist as it flaps
its wings downwards the smart bird
produces a force on the air down this in
turn produces a force on the bird
upwards for lift now at the edge of the
wings though since they're curved what
that's doing is actually scooping air
and pushing it behind it and what that
does is propel the bird forward that is
smart but will a flying robot bird fool
the real thing we have the chance to go
outside suddenly a lot of herring gulls
came in and they they're aggressive the
reaction was strange so they have to
learn what kind of bird is at the very
fact that the engineering community has
been trying to make a machine that flies
like a bird for a long time ever since
da Vinci
just goes to show how difficult it is to
actually do